you get so much fan mail where people
tell you you're the funniest thing on
the show it's going to your [ __ ] head
yeah just be a regular guy it's going to
my head yeah you think you're funny it's
going to my Fred am i right
I'm Rodney Dangerfield say you're wrong
I doubt it
what am I wrong about tell me about my
[ __ ] driving you don't know the first
thing about driving I'm sorry oh I've
never driven a car I got the same
[ __ ] license you've got yeah Jarius
this is driving you can see them this
morning guys he's going so fast a guy of
yellowfin UPS you were going so fast he
a guy Muslim couple nine thirty miles an
hour he a little slower you won't have
to because he's Ronnie and ready yeah
something wrong with you everything is
[ __ ] I think you know everything
about everything I know what I know you
know nothing about dry nothing so so I'm
going back to the car I'm getting ready
for the show I really hate this [ __ ]
guy he's going down the street I don't
know fast he's going but he's going
pretty fast
okay all of us on the [ __ ] highway
much seventh Avenue all of a sudden the
guy who's obviously not a good driver
swerves toward our lane like you don't
pull that from a parking [ __ ]
straight and then UNICOR suppose you're
going so fast you have to swerve and and
and then and guess who goes there's no
defensive driving going on 97 [ __ ]
speed you can pull the wool over some
people's eyes whoa I'm going thirty you
know you were going forward all the time
without looking you've got it like so he
swerves and I'm flying out I mean I'm in
fact ice warp so much you know when you
go up in space they do that simulation
where you're weightless what I mean how
you are not you are so wrong okay I was
playing passenger pinball I wasn't I was
it I didn't gasp out loud and go whoa
like whoa I have taken limos I've had
drivers yeah and I mean that's so
perfect I'm in the back of the car Mike
whoa yeah it's nice to blame the [ __ ]
guy who pulled out in front of me you're
a perv Lane me you could [ __ ] keep it
I can to some getting [ __ ] hate every
minute you keep us from getting here is
your enemy please this is our livelihood
over there drive aggressive [ __ ]
comes out when he drives yeah should he
know what you're doing my newspaper I'm
just [ __ ] in a freefall read my
newspaper even a pilot gives you a
heads-up when you might get some
turbulence I got time see give him
[ __ ] a heads up guys we don't have
time you're driving like a maniac I'm
driving like him anything you know what
it is he plays chicken with them yeah
sick he tries he stays as close as he
can to bright point I'm glad to see it
is free riding people's bumper
people's punishment you like you like
roller coasters right break with your
[ __ ] you your Drive you know what I
don't go to on a roller coaster I can't
take we work every day yes like being on
a roller you don't have to go to Coney
Island you can't read the paper it's
like whoa I'm like read your paper
ronnie has no empathy for the human
being in the back of his car he hates me
he hates me
I know you do yeah I could tell by the
way you crash me around I'm back there
okay and God forbid I don't pay
attention to him for ten minutes he gets
my attention by swerving my Terry are
you kidding me talk to psychiatrists
about it if you know you better talk to
y'all okay cuz I if I don't talk you
don't talk to mark it out that's right
that's when it happened
that's when it happens you're in love
with me do you bet it go back to [ __ ]
for days your is reorient you're in love
with me what are you talking about I'm
talking about if I'm not paying
attention to you you get my attention
sweet paper there's something wrong he's
reading the paper watch this yeah think
about what I'm saying in tribal and try
to make yourself [ __ ] in love with
you're not how we get over it
[ __ ] you're nice you're not Howard
get over doesn't you want to be Howard
then move to Vegas you start a radio
show I get upset yeah why do you think
that why do you think you're responding
to that God what are we gonna do later
today I'm gonna [ __ ] throw him all
over yeah we hit a nerve here yeah let
me ask you one other question Howard
when you are talking to him how is the
ride Oh smooth smooth as can be what is
it convincingly and a lot of times when
I put the divider up in the party really
to find at least five or six times I'll
go flying in the back yeah trust me I've
been watching this guy my almost my
entire adult life
he says trust me he says transparent as
can be
don't you have something to do yes I do
all right goodbye hmm right Fred Ronnie
gonna be a very special ride home today
you're gonna feel like you're in a
clothes dryer